ونبدا هنا او نواصل الى تطورات حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا حيث سجلت ضربات روسيه جديده
على مدن اوكرانيه بينها ديني برو وخرسون
بعد يوم من اعلان الاركان الاوكرانيه عن
مقتلي وجرحي اكثر من 500 جنديا روسي في
ضربات اوكرانيه لمتابعه التطورات
الميدانيه من الطرفين ينضم الينا من دني
برو مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج ومن موسكو
مراسله الجزيره رانيا الدريدي وابدا معك
عمر باخر التطورات
نعم عثمان
واكرمتوسطنطينيه
من الصواريخ اضافه الى هجمات بالطائرات
المسيره ايرانيه الصنع بعض هذه الصواريخ
ايضا
استخدم فيها صواريخ 300 عاليه التدمير
والتي تسببت باضرار كبيره في بعض المنشات
اضافه الى بعض المنازل المدنيه السلطات
الاوكرانيه لم تعلق على حديث القوات
الروسيه عن مقتل عسكريا اوكرانيا
القتلى الذين سقطتهم من المدنيون اثنان
مدنيون
سقط في مدينه اكرامي
وقع في ليله راس السنه في مدينه
الانفصاليه في مقابل
ان القوات الاوكرانيه وفقا لقياده الاركان
الساب- قائد ان استهدفت مكانا لتجمع
القوات المعبا جديدا من القوات الروسيه
اضافه الى مخازن لاسلحه وانها دمرت هذه
الاهداف تماما وان كانت القوات الاوكرانيه
لم تتحدث عن الارقام وتركت الامر همم سيرا
للتفسيرات ولكن كل المصائب هناك مصادر
كثيره همم ميدانيه يتحدث عن قتل بالمئات
وان كان الجانب الروسي 63 قتيلا ايضا هنا
في جنيفر وكذلك في مقاطعه
كلها تعرضت له هجمات من قبل القوات
الروسيه باستخدام اسلحه مختلفه القوات
الاوكرانيه في تصريحات السابقه لها قالت
انها اسقطت كل طائرات طائرات المسيره من
نوع شاهده التي بلغ عددها منذ بدايه هذا
العام منذ ثلاث ايام ثلاثه ايام استخدم
جلدها كان موجهها للسداد في مناطق حساسه
ومشات حيويه في مقاطعه كيف اضافه الى
مقاطعه اخرى اخيرا القوات الاوكرانيه
يتحدث عن ان ان قواتها يتمكن من السيطره
ناريا بشكل كامل فالطريق ار 66 الوصل بين
مدينتي كلمينا وصفت اوبا وان قواتها تتقدم
اكثر فاكثر باتجاه هذه المدن والبادات في
مقاطعه لوزتك هذا بالنسبه لاوكرانيا ماذا
تقول الروايه الروسيه العسكريه رانيا
عثمان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تستمر في
استهداف الاحياء السكنيه الحديث هذه المره
يدور عن مقتل مدني واصابه ثلاثه اخرين
بجروح من بينهم طفل يبلغ من العمر 14 عاما
همم يعني فضلا عن ذلك على سبيل المثال
احياء تعرضت خلال ساعات ال 24 الماضيه
لقذف الاوكراني باستخدام اكثر من 350 قديه
فتم قصف المدينه وطواحي المدينه
اكثر من 70 مره خلال اليوم الماضي فيما
يتعلق بالعمليات العسكريه وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تؤكد بان القوات المسلحه الروسيه
تشن عمليات هجوميه في عده محاور عثمان
الحديث يدور بدرجه الاولى عن محور الكوبرا
في مقاطعه خارقه بالاضافه الى محورين
محور دانيسكو ايضا الجنوبيه خلال الساعات
24 المانيا جراء العمليات العسكريه التي
نفذتها القوات المسلحه الروسيه بحسب
المعطيات وزاره الدفاع تم القضاء على نحو
400 عسكري همم اوكراني بالاضافه الى
القضاء على نحو 130 من المرتزقه الاجانب
وذلك خلال استهداف لمواقعهم في همم في
مدينه كرماطورس في مقاطعه دنياس حيث تم
قصف مواقع ما يسمى بالفيلق الاجنبي بحسب
المعطيات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فضلا عن
ذلك ايضا وزاره الدفاع ركز على استهداف
مواقع تمركز القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه هناك بالقرب من السكه الحديديه في
هذه المدينه تم استهداف مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيات تم القضاء على نحو 120 عسكريه
اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى تدمير كميات كبيره
من الاسلحه الحديثه يدور عن همم اكثر من
800 قديفه ناهيك عن منظمات
ملوخيه من طراز هاي مارس الامريكيه ولل
وقوف على تفاصيل ما تم تنفيذه من عمليات
عسكريه خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه لنتابع ما قاله في هذا الشان
الناطق باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اذا
كانشان كوفي
قضينا على اكثر من اربعين عسكريين
اوكرانيا في محوري كوبيانسكي الى جانب
مجموعتين
في مقاطعه خارجي
اكثر من 120 عسكريه بين قتيلا
وجريحيه الروسيه الثقيله كما تستمر قوتنا
في مهاجمه محور الدهنياتك وقضت على نحو 90
عسكريا اوكرانيا اما سلاح الجوي فقد قضى
على اكثر من 130 من المرتزقه الاجانب في
مدينه كرامته
شكرا لكم
دريدي من موسكو واشكر كذلك همم عمر الحاج
الذي كان معنا من دنيترون